this year is the year that you start
doing yoga and i mean for real this time
you're going to join the 36 million plus
americans who have taken up this
beautiful practice connecting yourself
with a millennia old tradition and
helping you flush out those nasty toxins
or
you know probably not but before you
grab a mat here's what yoga really does
to your body and brain
first of all yoga comes in many many
different styles
but generally speaking it involves some
amount of stretching and meditation now
despite what you may have read there's
no scientific evidence to support the
idea that yoga will flush out toxins
from your colon or anywhere else but
that doesn't mean these techniques can't
help your body in many other ways
take back pain for instance an estimated
80 percent of americans will suffer from
back pain at one point in their lives
but one study found that after just 6 to
12 yoga sessions participants reported
significantly less pain in their lower
back that's because certain yoga poses
stretch out your hamstrings which when
they're too tight can yank on your hip
flexors and strain your lower back but
the more you practice yoga the more
flexible your hamstrings get
for example in a 2015 study women
practiced a type of hatha yoga which
involves positions like downward dog and
triangle pose
they practice 90 minutes each week for
around 16 weeks straight and by the last
week they could reach 4 centimeters
closer to their toes than before thanks
to those loose hamstrings
now if you're also meditating during
those yoga sessions the flexibility
might not be the only benefit
after 7 to 16 weeks of meditative
activities participants in one study saw
a huge drop in c-reactive proteins in
their blood those proteins are linked to
inflammation which when you're overly
stressed can kick into overdrive
and over time that inflammation may
contribute to serious illnesses like
cardiovascular disease and cancer that's
where yoga's meditative qualities can
help researchers suspect that yoga may
reduce stress by interfering with the
central nervous system's ability to
release stress hormones plus studies
show that meditation-focused types of
yoga like yoga asana boost levels of
feel-good hormones like oxytocin in the
brain plus yoga is an exercise and
exercise in and of itself is a stress
reliever in fact the us department of
health and human services recommends two
and a half to five hours a week of light
to moderate exercise that can include
workouts like yoga brisk walking or
swimming and to be fair any amount of
regular exercise is most likely going to
reduce anxiety elevate mood and improve
sleep and self-esteem
so while yoga might have an edge in the
flexibility department and mindfulness
department there are plenty of other
activities you can try to get fit
but as long as it gets you moving and
maybe gives you some new friends why not
give it a try
[Music]
you